hey jakey the place on the corner is
serving lemonade and you get to keep the
jar
it's pretty cool yes
that's very cool scully will you excuse
me just one moment
oh sure guys guys guys
scully has a mason jar full of lemonade
you called us in here to tell us that no
i called you in here to change your
lives before you see a mere five minutes
ago hitchcock introduced me to his new
goldfish who lives in
oh an identical mason jar oh this isn't
gonna end well
there are two possible outcomes and
we're gonna bet on which one happens
first so
will hitchcock put fish food in scully's
lemonade or will skully drink
hitchcock's goldfish now you would think
that putting fish food into lemonade
hitchcock just drank his own fish
what no
have a nice weekend peralta yeah nothing
special yeah you gotta come you missed
scully's birthday
it was kind of a big one nobody showed
at the party
guys guys guys we missed scully's
birthday and it was a big one i know
i panicked and said i had to go to the
vet because my puppy cat got sick
i said i had to take my mom to get birth
control pills that's better than my
excuse
i said i had to go to my girls bat
mitzvahs squad
we missed scully's birthday and it was a
big one
i told them i was in ecuador i think
they bought it we got to make it up to
them
let's give them cash everyone put in 20
each uh
yes i'll cover you hey scully huh
we're sorry that we missed your party
well don't worry about it
yo you all had stuff to do yes the
capital of ecuador is quito
oh anyway happy birthday from all of us
thanks guys you you're the best
can't believe it the fake birthday
worked
you're a genius we're both geniuses
traffic is shut down civilians are being
funneled into checkpoints good i just
wish my guys over here could be a little
more efficient
yeah i'm looking at you detective fuzzy
paws this is amy hates dogs amy or amy
extra stress
amy it's both amy's i'm under a lot of
pressure and also that dog is a piece of
trash
okay until something else is going on
you don't have to pretend to be mad at
the dog first of all i'm not pretending
that dog sucks also
my period's late i think i might be
pregnant oh damn i can't be pregnant
jake and i agreed to wait at least a
year until we tried i haven't found a
nobi i'm not on any preschool waiting
list and i spent
all of yesterday in a room with
hitchcock in his new cologne which can't
be good for the baby it is
literally called zika okay relax
you're probably not pregnant it's
entirely possible hitchcock's cologne
disrupted your cycle
right yes that is a very real
possibility so i can spare four
uniformed officers to do hourly pass-bys
at the bodegas south of fourth
and i'll coordinate with the um hourly
pass-bys of the
wait what was that that was me talking
about hourly pass-bys oh yeah i heard
about the hourly pass buys
twice i meant that subtle side look
there was no subtle side look you're
right cause it wasn't subtle it was an
unsubtle side look at that dress in the
shop
why are you being such a nut job about
looking for a wedding dress because
being a female sergeant is difficult i
have to work twice as hard to gain my
officers respect and
looking at girly dresses isn't going to
help plus it's a new job and i need to
make it a priority
dude i get that but if you want a
beautiful wedding dress you deserve to
find one look there are no cops around
nobody's gonna see you why don't we just
take our break now try one on
okay okay okay okay okay
okay hell yeah
they are closed we will come back later
yeah
so what do you think i don't love the
sash
but it's fine i'm just gonna get it what
that's the first one you tried on
i once saw you look at 54 different
accordion folders and not buy
any of them due to weak tabs i file hard
i need strong
tabs i just don't want to take up any
more time your break's not even a
quarter done
i'll stay another 10 minutes you'll stay
until i dismiss you irene
music now spin what are you doing here
isn't it your day off yes stalker it is
my day off but i'm here to meet charles
did you hear what you did last night
drink it jake
drink it what's up your tiny sleeve
why is there a bow tie in here wait a
minute jake peralta will you be my best
man
yes yes a thousand times yes
wow best man so you're gonna set up shop
in a strip club
what kind of shop would i set up hand
sanitizer
i would sell hand sanitizer and no i was
hoping that my best man duties would be
all whiskey and cigars but this is
charles we're talking about so we've got
two straight days of wedding planning
plus he gave me this to prep fancy broad
gum
it means fancy groom and danish
according to charles the danes throw the
most beautiful weddings in the world
and the most violent funerals
this does not look like something you'd
be into normally yes but i am now
charles's
fur lover best man danish so it is my
duty
to support him no matter what weird
crazy charlesy ideas he has
let's do this there he is my groom
hello my big beautiful bm best man just
best man is fine i hope you're rested
we're gonna be on our feet all day i'm
totally prepared i even bought some
nurse shoes
love them mm-hmm let me grab this and
grab this
let me grab this first out kagan smega
cake tasting
wow hey charles can we talk in the
briefing room for a second there's a
question i got to ask you hmm
it's happening jake is gonna pop the
question
he's gonna ask me to be his bm no bm
best man is a common abbreviation no one
but you has ever
used it i am so relieved i thought maybe
he was gonna ask one of amy's brothers
or
who sarge hey man come on charles
okay so i know this is a lot to ask no
it's not i want to do it
you want to cover my shift this weekend
so i can go to the white plains mall and
meet daryl strawberry at the opening of
a cell phone store
yes that's exactly what i was hoping
you'd ask great
thanks you sure it's okay
i'm very happy about it that'll be fun
it'll be fun uh look at my smile
i have to go now
my god jake what do you say bud
will you be my bm yes yes a million
times yes
in your face terry what i'm holding a
sparkler for you i helped organize a lot
of this
well you could stick that sparkle up
your butt i'm the best man
there's something i'd like to show you
captain
terry crushed it
it works i've never been more proud of
you for anything in your life
i mean i've solved a lot of cases for
you and yet crime has continued
don't worry fire department is on the
job hear that jeffords we're gonna die
in here we're marked for death okay calm
down i have an idea when my parents were
fighting my dad got scary
i would take my little brother upstairs
and to distract him
i'd teach him dance moves
or kind of dance moves mostly 80s
hip-hop he loves salt and pepper no
i won't be doing that
salt and pepper you say mozy forward
naming lights butt pop comb your hair
now typing motion pull it back jump
forward
pelvic pump you got it now all we need
to do is run it all together and do it
at full speed
i must say jeffords this dancing is
quite distracting i've completely
forgotten that we're trapped here in
this death box
inspected by bozo beverly between clown
shows
you know what sir i don't think you are
thrusting
your butt enough before the naming
lights
yes yes i felt that god i love that note
back to the top okay i was saying five
six seven eight can you distract her i
got this
hey me you come out with any new binders
recently i don't want to talk about
binders rosa all right that was my big
gun she's just gonna feel this
not necessarily i was just checking to
see if there's anything we can do to
help and i hate to say it but i think
there is
oh you think he's gonna get me drugs
from evidence uh
no something way weirder is happening
hit it jefferson
[Music]
distracted
foreign
you